heather locklear rushed to the hospital
after reported overdose call the 56 year
old actress was hospitalized Monday
hours after being released on bail
following her arrest on charges of
misdemeanor battery Sunday night a
spokesperson for the Ventura County
Sheriff's Department tells ET quote we
did go to her house this afternoon along
with the fire department and ambulance
personnel and when everyone arrived on
scene they determined that it was a
medical issue and a patient was
transport from the house to a local
hospital according to TMZ Heather was
taken to the hospital after police
received a call from someone at her home
reporting someone had overdosed the
hospitalization comes less than a day
after a source claimed Heather's family
had to call the police because she was
quote acting erratically and threatened
to kill herself
and was later arrested for reportedly
punching a deputy and kicking an EMT
while being placed on a gurney
he learned Locklear was expected to head
back to rehab after her arrest and that
her family was relieved she would be
going back into treatment